in watching the Supreme Court today I
thought it was very it's a very
beautiful process I hope that democracy
of this country will continue process
Donald Trump sounding pretty confident
while the Supreme Court's sounding
pretty skeptical on the case that could
alter the course of American History the
top court hearing oral arguments on
whether Colorado can ban former
president Trump from its state ballot
and they seem to be leaning in favor of
the former president Colorado
disqualified Trump from its ballot and
citing section three of the 14th
Amendment saying he's ineligible for the
White House under the US Constitution's
Insurrection Clause despite the fact
that no court has ever convicted him of
insurrection but here's how bad it got
for the Democrats the Obama appointed
Justice Kagan questioned the entire
foundation of the
case why should a single state have the
ability to make this determination not
only for their own citizens but for the
rest of the nation it sounds awfully
National to me if you weren't from
Colorado and you were from Wisconsin or
you were from Michigan and it really you
know what the Michigan secretary of
state did is going to make the
difference
between you know whether candidate a is
elected or candidate B is elected I man
it seems quite extraordinary doesn't it
here's also how you know the Democrats
lost big at the court it was like a
funeral for the liberal media the
Republican justices all six of them will
defend their boy and keep Trump on the
ballot this argument did not go well for
the Trump Challengers and that's to put
it mildly I probably have some other
adjectives that I won't um say on air he
is the one who helped cause helped fan
the Flames that led to the Insurrection
however they decide now it's time to
disenfranchise a disenfranchise her and
they're just looking for the exits it's
just bizarre to me to watch the system
continue to bend over backwards uh as he
plays his chicken game with our with our
syst okay uh I think we've gotten uh all
the illegal analysis we're going to get
out of President Trump you know it's odd
there because can I just this was
actually an opportunity for her to come
him to come out and say no it's not
because it was he wants to talk about
himself oh oh the serious legal analysis
after CNN judge what struck you today
listening to these arguments you know I
have uh for the last few years often
wondered about my role as a prosecutor
and as a public official I mean the
system sometimes seems rigged there are
two systems of Justice we've been
talking about it but as I sat there and
listened I it was a great day for me and
hopefully for many Americans because we
saw the United States Supreme Court go
beyond the issue of politics recognize
that its job was to analyze the
constitution in a textualist way and an
interpretation that was not about
politics and when you saw them or heard
them they it was clear that they were
United on some issues and the that it
was a moment that to me transcended
politics and I loved it okay they proved
today how wrong the left was in
predicting that you know this is all
about politics and you know they would
make arguments that had nothing to do
with the law all of these arguments had
to do with the law the the the
fundamental question is the 14th
Amendment the 14th amendment was enacted
to restrict state power not to add state
power and for them to interpret uh an
Insurrection where nobody's been
convicted of insurrection as a cause and
give one Secretary of State the ability
just as we heard I think it was Justice
Kagan talking about to affect the United
States and literally determine who will
be our next president is antithetical to
the to the Constitution there's no role
for the states here unless Congress
gives the states the author Authority
they did not do that and I you know it
was interesting that that Sodom mayair
who was the outliner said you know there
is a lack of due process she said that
President Trump has not been afforded
that Pro due process as it relates to
whether or not he's an insurrectionist
so it was legally uh he was convicted by
the mainstream media the mainstream
media believe that they are the courts
and the justices the left is so
frustrated because they've controlled so
much and all of a sudden they get to the
top court and they realize that they may
lose on the law yeah I heard katangi
Brown Jackson also sounding very
doubtful Herold uh listening to the
arguments presented by the Colorado
attorneys one of the great things about
our country and we sometimes forget and
I um I I try not to is that our legal
system works we this these are Judges
well I disagree uh judge Pi on this one
the these are Supreme Court Justices
nine of them who've been appointed Ed by
presidents but who took an oath of
office and we shouldn't be surprised uh
that these justices because they were
appointed by democrats nor should
Democrats be surprised when a republican
appointed Justice mightt agree with them
this is what our judicial system this is
what our framers had in mind when when
Justice s mayor said due process had not
been given to Mr trump it didn't matter
to her who Mr Trump was he's an American
and you can't deny someone an
opportunity to be on the ballot if they
hadn't been convicted of something
matter of fact he had been charged with
uh leading an Insurrection nor has he
been convicted of anything furthermore
the record in Colorado you can't take
the record of a partisan um uh uh
hearing which which is what it was it
was a Democrat Le although they had
Republicans on there too and use that
that's not a trial they used that as a
record for what they did so this was
absolutely I believe what was supposed
to happen uh and we don't have a
decision there but it seems as if that's
what they're what they're saying the
president now president Trump needed
some good news on the legal front the
the the absolute immunity case has been
rejected by the DC Circuit Court uh and
you had a judge here award a uh a
defendant I think $80 million or so in
some case so the the president president
Trump had every right to say what he
said today I'm not sure it was a
beautiful process I would just call it
America the process working uh but
president has every right to
characterize it how he wants to
characteriz how did you uh characterize
the process I would just make it well I
thought it was beautiful listening to it
this morning but I do think that um
whereas America believes that the
Supreme Court is just hopelessly divided
about a third of the opinions that they
release are 90 and you don't hear about
them just like you don't hear about all
the planes that landed safely this one
however if it does go 90 and that looks
like the way it will go in Trump's favor
you'll hear about it and it will be good
to then get the process going the bigger
story for me is not this one Trump's
going to be on the ballot it's going to
be fine uh it's the story that we did at
the beginning I'm still shell shocking
yeah I just cannot imagine what this
White House is going to do Greg it
seemed like the media had their uh
expectations raised a little too high
for this argument I love watching CNN
they officially have more people on
their panel than viewers have you seen
their ratings by the way the Democrats
aren't worried President Biden says he
already spoke to th Good Marshall and
he's good with he's good with Banning
Trump no you do see the the reason why
the the the media is melting down is
because they hoaxed thems eles into
believing the Insurrection hoax because
to believe that hoax you have to believe
that it's the first ever unarmed
Insurrection uh it's the first where
many participants were LED in in taking
selfies it's the first ever Insurrection
where the only casualty was an unarmed
female protester who was shot dead it's
the first ever Insurrection where the
pre president was there giving a
constitutionally protected speech where
he implored citizens to protest
peacefully so that's crazy so you got to
remember who's behind the Insurrection
hoax same people that were behind Russia
gate they just switched out the subjects
and the verbs but it's interesting to
see a party that claims to be protecting
democracy trying so hard to get the
opposition off the ballot so democracy
is thed if you want election
interference you got it it's right there
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else